[Applause]
used to be a carpenter teacup there's a
list of people that want to toss them
off Turks oh you're seeing this stuff I
finally puke you got
[Music]
I trust you Irish
in run Barry run he wanted support
I were you would start running I gotta
go you ran out of here yes Joe I'm
pregnant we're gonna need more diapers
diapers you keep drawing buddy I keep
drawing I'm gonna figure this out
machete vs. Cisco on the flash next week
we got so many new characters to break
down so there's a new round I'll say
flash ring giveaway just because
everybody's asking for the flash ring
over the Justice League tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
or leave a comment on this video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this but
obviously I'm hyping up Danny Trejo on
the flash but there's several other new
characters that they just introduced
especially with the Joe West tag from
the end of last week's episode I'm
pregnant we're gonna need more diapers
so if you wonder why so many people in
your timelines are talking about Daniel
west if you're not a big comic book
reader I'll explain all that but
starting with the big stuff first the
new characters they're introducing next
week are breacher who's gonna be gypsies
father that's Danny Trejo scare achter
he's a big comic book villain from the
new 52 but I don't think that he's going
to be like a super evil person on the
flash I think he's just gonna be really
angry and think that cisco is not good
enough for it is a result of that
he's going to kick his ass like you see
him going after them in the trailer when
you see those two big blasts of red
energy hitting the flash in the
elongated man here
that's breacher coming after them so it
looks like something happens with Cisco
like he says in the trailer you better
start running now they need to cut a
grindhouse version of the trailer where
it's just Danny Trejo chasing Cisco down
so you have the relationship comedy
stuff happening where it's like the
angry dad chasing him down but it also
seems like Barry is trying to protect
the elongated man because so many people
are after him too so a lot of the comedy
of the episode is that Barry has to
protect his friends and this new person
who you kind of hear in the trailer that
he's not super happy about like he says
he's a dirty cop so sort of moving into
elongated man territory you get a bit of
a preview for what his powers look like
there's gonna be all kinds of jokes does
every part of his body stretch out so we
know that on the flash he's going to lie
about where he got his powers from but
very clearly in the promo they pasted
his picture up on that board of 12 so
either they figure out that he was on
that bus or they think he's on the bus
and he wasn't on the bus so there's
gonna be some twist in the episode about
where he got his powers but I think
based on some of the evidence in the
last week's episode where the thinker
talked about how people are easily
manipulated and he's trying to create
these twelve and manipulate them that
the elongated man was somebody who was
down on his luck just like Hazzard was
so if the thinker's creating a villain
team-up wouldn't you go after a dirty
cop but I think the twist is is because
elongated man is a good character in the
comics is that he'll have a change of
heart
like not all of the 12 people on the bus
will be total dirtbags like Kilgore is
very clearly a villain he'll do whatever
the thinker tells him to do but I
wouldn't be surprised because he does
come off as a dirtbag if he flip-flops
allegiances a couple times like they
make you wonder if he really is working
with team flash or if he's just a double
agent for the thinker but like I said I
think it's supposed to be a more hopeful
twist so hopefully they won't kill him
at the end of the season after he tries
to help save team flash usually that's
the twist is like the dirtbag becomes a
good person by the end of the season and
then something really bad happens to
them so we'll see how his character
works out I'm not super familiar with
the actor but he's been on a couple
other series before but moving into
diaper territory Joe West the baby
Cecile there are so many different ways
they could shake this down so when Barry
said we're going to need more diapers it
implied that they already knew that
babies were on the
way so it sounds like Joe will tell
everybody else
hey Cecile just told me that she's
pregnant we're having another child and
everybody's really happy about that
they're really happy about the wedding
of bearing iris coming up and that's all
they're thinking about but then later on
iris probably finds out that she's
pregnant in surprise we're gonna need
more diapers so of all the gibberish
that Barry blurted out in episode 1
they've already paid off three of those
things and we've only had three episodes
so far so I wouldn't be surprised if
they paid off those Easter eggs before
we got to the mid-season finale the one
thing I'm not super sure about is iris
being pregnant that would be crazy if
they did that before the mid-season
finale because you already have this
Cecile baby on the way so it just feels
like way too much to get everybody
pregnant all at the same time for those
of you wondering why everybody's talking
about Daniel West because of Joe and
Cecile's big twist
Daniel West was the reverse-flash of the
new 52 comics they had changed the
familial relationships so iris West had
a brother named Daniel instead of Wally
like the TV show there's a number of
changes that the TV show has already
made to the classic comics like in the
comics Wally West is a ginger character
during the new 52 he became an
african-american more recently the
african-american Wally West in the
comics found out that Daniel West is
actually his father so there's all kinds
of crazy stuff happening in the comics
that doesn't totally make sense so don't
worry about that for the TV show it's
just the idea that if you're gonna go
with comic book characters there are
only a couple of West's that they
haven't used the names of so far the
biggest one being Daniel it what
happened to him in the comics is that he
just fell on hard times
they grew up in an abusive household so
obviously a lot of that they're probably
not gonna do on the flash but that led
to him getting speedforce powers then
because he led such a bad life and
gotten in trouble so much he was so
disillusioned with society he decided to
use his speed force powers for evil and
that's when he became the reverse-flash
a lot of you have asked if they're gonna
give the twins to Cecile like they'll do
the tornado twins but it'll be Joe and
Cecile that have them and that's how you
get to Bart Allen eventually but when
they do really big characters they
try to be as faithful as possible so I
don't know exactly how they're gonna
shake down this Irish pregnancy
storyline or if they're gonna go in a
completely different direction so we'll
have to wait for some more evidence but
think about it this way
could you imagine a TV show like the
flash that's built around them taking
down metahumans the flash learning about
new abilities them unlocking new comic
book characters taking care of three
separate babies in next season that
would be crazy
so obviously there's gonna be some big
twist they'll find some easy workaround
because I feel like that would bring the
plot to a grinding halt
if you have to have a baby scene in
every single episode but a lot of that's
just speculation just because people say
that they're pregnant doesn't mean that
the babies will be born although I don't
think the show is so pessimistic that it
would kill a baby
so if Cecile is pregnant and she doesn't
miscarry or something like that I think
the baby will be born even if she winds
up dying by the end of the season but
things just got super crazy and if you
don't know what happened is they just
introduced a character on legends of
tomorrow from the Black Adam comics I
can't say her name out loud because it's
like a banned term it's the name of a
terrorist organization so they're just
calling her sorry Tomas that's just her
name from the comics that was also a TV
show based on her character where there
was an amulet so there's a lot of Easter
eggs for that but the way they're
explaining her powers is that she kind
of has Airbender powers like paying or
Korra so if you ever watch Last
Airbender that's kind of out works
there's a whole bunch of other videos
that are coming up this week that I'll
try to get through just look at the top
comment that I pin in the comments for
announcements about what videos are
coming next congratulations to Mike
Julian you're the latest giveaway winner
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for my flash episode 3 video and you can
click here for brand new Star Wars the
last Jedi footage thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight